we have been given five digits one two
three four and five and along with that
we have this question using these five
digits
how many three-digit odd numbers can be
formed first case when repetition is not
allowed and second when repetition is
allowed by repetition not being allowed
they mean we cannot consider numbers
like 1 3 1 or 2 2 4 which have repeated
digits let's understand the first part
read the question well how many
three-digit odd numbers odd is the key
word here as we have been asked for
three-digit numbers let's make three
slots what do we mean by odd a number is
odd if it is not divisible by 2 is 342
odd no it's not odd as it is divisible
by 2
what about 531 is this odd yes it is
because it is not divisible by 2
similarly 325 and 243 are odd in simple
words this three-digit number will be
odd if it's unit digit is odd so based
on the condition we have the three-digit
number can end with a 1 or end with a 3
or end with a 5 correct these are the
only three possibilities here now focus
on the first possibility the number ends
with a 1 in how many ways can we fill
the first slot or the hundredth slot
what do you think the digit 1 is gone so
the hundredths place can be filled with
any one of the remaining four digits 2 3
4 or 5 4 ways in which it can be filled
what about the second slot the digit 1
is gone and another digit out of these 4
is gone into the hundreds place only
three digits remain so the second slot
can be filled in three ways with 1 in
the unit's
yes and as we are filling the first and
the second slot we multiply this and is
always multiplication four times three
is twelve
given these five digits there are twelve
ways in which we can form a three-digit
number with one as its units digit are
we done
no we still have to look at these two
cases in the second case the digit 3 is
gone the first slot can be filled with
one or a two or a four or a five four
ways as two digits are gone the tens
place can be filled in three ways again
as we are filling the first and the
second slot we have a multiplication
sign here given these five digits there
are 12 ways in which we can form a
three-digit number with 3 as its units
digit and similarly we get a 12 here as
well let's zoom out slightly what do we
do with these three numbers do we add
them or multiply them to know the answer
just use plain English the unit's digit
is 1 & 3 & 5 or should we say that the
unit's digit can be 1 or 3 or a 5 of
course it's an or based on the condition
given the unit's digit can be 1 or 3 or
5 and or implies + adding these three we
get the answer as 36 ways 36 ways in
which we can form three-digit odd
numbers using these five digits now this
was slightly long and a more logical way
of solving this now that we know the
concept let's look at a quicker way to
solve it we know it is a three-digit
number what is the condition given to us
the condition is that the number should
be odd
remember a golden rule whenever we are
given a condition start with it as the
condition is about the numbers being odd
we can be sure that it depends on the
unit's digit so we start off with the
unit's digit slot in how many ways can
the slot it can be filled with a one or
a three or a five threeways now we can
move on to the other two slots one digit
is gone it doesn't matter what digit it
is if one digit is gone then four remain
the hundredths place can be filled in
four ways if the unit's digit is filled
with one any digit from two three four
of five can be in the hundreds place if
the unit's digit is filled with three
any digit from one to four or five can
be in the hundreds place and when two
digits are used for the hundreds and the
unit's place just three remain the
second slot can be filled in three ways
and we multiply these to get the answer
thirty-six ways we got the same answer
but a lot quicker some of you would be
thinking why start with the condition
what if we don't let's say we decide to
start with the hundreds place in how
many ways can we fill the hundreds place
digit we can fill it with any of the
five digits five ways having used one
digit here the tens place can be filled
in four ways and now we come to the
unit's place in how many ways can we
fill the unit's place can we say three
ways as three digits are left maybe not
let's say we used a one here we have two
three four and five left say I pick a
three here now in how many ways can the
unit's digit be filled it has to be odd
the only odd digit that remains is five
it can be filled in just one way and
that's five let's take another scenario
say we fill the hundreds place with two
and we picked a four in the tens place
now tell me in how many ways can we fill
the unit's digit one three or five all
will keep the number odd in this case
there are three ways in which the unit's
digit can be filled so we end up with
conflicting answers if we don't start
with the condition when forming numbers
remember to start with the condition
there are 36 ways in which we can form
three-digit odd numbers using these five
digits if repetition is not allowed and
what if repetition is allowed
remember life becomes really easy if
repetition is allowed let's solve it on
a new page using these five digits
how many three-digit odd numbers can be
formed if repetition is allowed okay
let's solve the second part we are
talking about three-digit numbers here
and they have to be odd let's start with
the condition in how many ways can we
fill the unit's digit as the number has
to be odd we can fill the unit's digit
with either a 1 or a 3 or a 5 3 ways in
which the unit's digit can be filled we
are done with the condition in how many
ways can we fill the hundreds place now
what do you think as one digit is used
here the hundredths place can be filled
in four ways correct no it's not
don't forget repetition is allowed we
can use the same digit here as well five
ways in which the hundredths place can
be filled any one of the five digits and
what about the tens place again it can
be filled with any one of the five
digits five ways as we are filling the
first and the second and the third slot
we multiply these numbers we get the
answer as 75 ways there are 75
three-digit odd numbers we can form
using these five digits if repetition is
allowed here's my last question in this
session if repetition is allowed do we
have to start with the condition let's
say we start with the hundredths place
it can be filled with any of the five
digits it will be the same with the tens
digit as repetition is allowed and the
unit's digit again can be folded three
ways the answer does not
even if we start with the hundreds place
if repetition is allowed we don't really
have to start with the condition don't
stress yourself out by having to
remember this as a general rule just
start with the condition that's how we
deal with numbers with a condition we
will cover a few more interesting
examples in the coming sessions
you